magic spoon tastes exactly like your
favorite childhood breakfast cereals but
it has no sugar lots of protein it's
keto and low carb friendly it's
delicious without the guilt get five
dollars off when you click my link below
and use the promo code pacman i want to
start today talking a little bit about
so-called freedom and the reason i say
so called is because much of the
discussion of freedom much of the use of
the word freedom
is actually coming from extreme
authoritarians
who only believe in the type of freedom
that benefits them they only believe in
the type of freedom that allows them to
impose
whatever they want unto everybody else
restricting everybody else's freedom
it's an extremely authoritarian and
historically
popular with fascists perspective on
what freedom means the freedom to tell
others what to do
for example or the freedom to
stay in power even when you lost an
election it's freedom
to be extremely authoritarian no matter
what anybody else wants says or believes
and in the past we've talked about the
people that claim their rights we saw
this early with covet a lot actually
they focus on these are my rights they
claim their rights
but they're obsessed with their rights
in a complete and total vacuum from the
responsibilities
that come with those rights and that
allow everybody to maintain those rights
and this is sort of a similar thing much
the same way
freedom
during the pandemic that's been preached
by a lot of these people
means my version of freedom only which
is a very authoritarian concept and
perspective and you know some examples
by freedom the state of florida under
republican governor ron desantis is a
really good example
there's a very good article in the
guardian that explains that the theme
and the concept of freedom
pushed by desantis and the florida
legislature
is actually authoritarianism cloaked as
freedom look at the so-called
stop woke act
and that imposes from above
from people who know nothing about
education what is allowed to be taught
in individual classrooms they talk about
it as freedom but it's actually
extremely authoritarian republicans are
talking about in florida an extreme
abortion ban without even an exception
for rape or incest that's an
outrageously authoritarian way
of telling women what they have to do
outlawing mask requirements in all sorts
of places that's not freedom and liberty
it's authoritarian you're imposing one
option
on all sorts of organizations despite
claiming to be about freedom they claim
to be against regulating business and
yet they say we are banning
masking or vaccination requirements and
even in the context of the big lie
around the 2020 election
they talk about the freedom to have only
legal votes counted that's what they say
and all of these catch phrases
but ultimately all of it is in service
to the wildly dictatorial authoritarian
idea
that when you lose an election you can
find some way to stay in power and
there's few things more dictatorial than
that
there's some really interesting research
into the concept of competitive
authoritarianism you can google that
phrase and you'll find a ton of academic
papers about it and what competitive
authoritarianism refers to is you have
in theory the front of democratic
institutions and electoral competition
whoever convinces voters that they are
the better candidate the better choice
wins
and gets to govern
but it's actually unfair competition
where incumbents try to use all sorts of
mechanisms including courts remember
trump with the 63
court filings the media going out at 2am
and putting into the media the narrative
that i actually want
manipulation of the voting systems
telling and telling georgia to do this
in arizona to do that they're using the
court's media and the voting systems to
stay in power even when they lose when
there is a front
of fair
democratic institutions and that's a lot
of what 2020 looked like there's a very
good vox article which says you what
these people want to do
is strike a balance where they want to
rig and control elections just enough to
stay in power but don't make it all look
democratic so that
citizens believe they are choosing and
they don't rise up and and it often
doesn't quite work i mean it didn't
quite work for them in 2020 in that
ultimately joe biden was still
inaugurated the president but this
concept of calling things the opposite
of what they are referring to a total
ban on mass mandates as freedom when in
reality it's the opposite of freedom
it's really explored and fleshed out in
detail in george orwell's 1984 it's
almost cliche it's almost apocryphal
uh tons of people love to misquote or
misuse or they misunderstand aspects of
1984 and they talk about 1984 when it
really doesn't apply but this opposite
naming by authoritarians it's straight
out of the book
um in 1984 you have the slogan war is
peace
freedom is slavery
that's fundamentally at a core level
what we're talking about here and in
fact one of the scariest things is that
if you look historically
fascism
has a long history of being called
freedom
fascism uses
explicitly populist
libertarian-sounding rhetoric and they
talk about you know a heroic mass effort
to get back to some p previous period
where we we had greatness and we you
know trump literally using the greatness
thing um it often demands loyalty to a
single leader it often leads to a cult
of personality and and unquestioned
obedience to whatever the leader says he
says the election was stolen it was
stolen and we will all repeat it
uncritically whether we truly believe it
or not
historically reminds us of many
different things
and sort of like the calling card of
those four years of trump and it
continues because the rallies have
restarted which we'll talk about a
little bit later
we have major news
in terms of the more than 700 cases
against alleged trump rioters there's
more than 700 total cases now and one of
the things we've been wondering waiting
for and thinking about is will there be
more serious charges a lot of the
charges even though collectively this
was an attempted insurrectious coup to
install the guy who lost in the white
house that was the general point of it
to really charge people with anything
even remotely close to that
requires
pretty
you've got it close to have these people
dead to rights and really be able to
prove
what they intended in participating in
those riots and that's really tough
we've talked about perjury people
perjure themselves all the time in court
using the term perjury colloquially but
proving perjury is quite difficult and
you really don't see even a small
fraction of instances of perjury
actually prosecuted a lot of the stuff
we're talking about with january 6th
including sedition
is quite difficult to prove and thus it
makes it it makes it tough to say we're
going to charge people with that that
has now changed and things are changing
very very dramatically
the leader of the oath keepers
and 10 other individuals have been
indicted in federal court for seditious
conspiracy and other offenses related to
the u.s capitol breach this is sort of a
crossing of the rubicon when it comes to
the january 6th riots and the justice
department publication says that a
federal grand jury in dc returned an
indictment charging 11 defendants with
seditious conspiracy one of the main
charges here is a guy named elmer stuart
rhodes iii
a 56 year old texan who is the founder
and leader of the oath keepers that's a
right-wing militia type group rhodes was
arrested in texas
another another guy edward vallejo 63
also charged with seditious conspiracy a
bunch of other previously named
defendants have been charged eight other
individuals affiliated with the oath
keepers have been charged in the
investigation and they remain as
defendants in two related cases these
are really really serious charges
the seditious conspiracy indictment
alleges that following the 2020 election
rhodes conspired with co-defendants
to oppose by force the execution of the
laws governing the transfer of
presidential power by january 20th
they via encrypted and private
communications coordinated and planned
to travel to dc around january 6th
to bring weapons to support their
operation
they did travel and they conspired
through a variety of manners and means
including organizing into teams prepared
to use force to transport firearms and
ammunition they recruited people they
organized trainings to teach and learn
paramilitary combat tactics on and on
and on
uh with the point of preventing the
lawful transfer of presidential power
these are really really serious charges
and it's sort of i don't know that we
would call this funny but one of the
things that the wright has been saying
and tucker's been saying this and other
fox news hosts and others saying
if this was an insurrectious coup if
they were doing sedition why haven't
they been charged with that in fact just
hours before
the charges
fox news dude brit hume although to be
honest i don't even know if he's still
at fox news but brit hume who for a long
time was that uh he is still a political
analyst on fox news he tweeted here's a
thought let's base our view on whether
one six was an insurrection on whether
those arrested are charged with
insurrection so far none has been within
hours charges for seditious conspiracy
to prevent a peaceful transfer of power
i had tweeted
so i guess they were waiting on the more
serious charges and a cnn legal analyst
asha rangapa
said i don't think they were waiting the
more serious charges are also more
complex and can take longer to gather
evidence and put together if you look at
the indictment it is incredibly detailed
and you can't get that information
overnight so as vox has now
reported
these charges really change
the whole feel
of the riots um
vox writing seditious conspiracy occurs
when two or more people work together to
plan to overthrow the government or the
x or prevent the execution of its laws
and that now on the basis of these
charges
this has really stepped things up
before we had seen disorderly conduct
obstructing an official proceeding
before congress and even there we've
seen sentences close to four years
seditious conspiracy carries a potential
sentence of 20 years in prison and
importantly these new charges refute the
argument that the entire riots were
overblown that's been a story we hear
from many right-wingers this is all
overblown it wasn't an attempted coup it
wasn't an attempted insurrection and
nobody's been charged with anything like
that well now they have
and we may see we may see
instead of 41-month sentences
we could see 10 12
potentially up to 20 but probably not
year sentences and that completely
changes the entire story about what
happened on january 6th could there be
even more serious charges maybe maybe
we're going to wait and see
let me know your thoughts you can find
me on twitter at dpakman and tell me
what you think about this
it is a brand new year maybe you have
goals around getting in better shape
maybe cutting back on sugar
that's why you should check out our long
time sponsor magic spoon magic spoon
tastes exactly like the delicious sweet
breakfast cereals you loved as a kid but
magic spoon has zero grams of sugar 14
grams of protein and only four net carbs
so it's perfect if you're doing low carb
or keto or if like me you just try to
limit your sugar intake you can build
your own variety pack with flavors like
cocoa fruity frosted peanut butter
cinnamon cookies and cream waffle maple
blueberry that's my favorite
magic spoon lets you enjoy a sweet
delicious snack without the guilt you
can stick to your goals and still treat
yourself and if you don't love magic
spoon as much as i do they'll give you
all of your money back no questions
asked magic spoon is giving my audience
five dollars off when you go to
magicspoon.com
pacman and use the promo code pacman our
program is an audience funded program
and i would love for you to sign up at
joinpackman.com we do an extra show
every day for our members you can use
the coupon code wow 22 to get a sizable
discount and instant access to all of
these great membership perks all right
folks the the 2022 midterms have
officially started and i say that
because donald trump's rallies are back
not only does donald trump have a rally
scheduled for january 29th in texas but
this past saturday a few days ago donald
trump held his first rally of the year
it is already in support of 2022
candidates we are in the 2022 midterms
this rally was in florence arizona uh it
was an extremely dangerous rally it was
a rally
um
incredibly corrosive to democracy based
on the things that donald trump was
saying and the entire speech quite
frankly sounded like a 2020 election
speech
but it's 2022 and when you hear donald
trump talk about information will soon
come out of arizona you might be saying
about which election is he's not talking
about the election
in 2020 even though now it's 20 yes he
is he's still talking about the 2020
election and at this point
if you believe any of this stuff you
were truly beyond reach now the elect
the rally rather had all of the normal
stuff all of the normal trump lies
trump's left eye swollen almost
completely shut i don't know that
trump's left eye open during the entire
rally we still don't know what that's
about
blacks for trump strategically placed on
the stage right behind trump the crowd
getting bored very quickly until he says
the craziest of crazy things at which
point they show signs of life and we're
going to just look at a few different
moments of this and to me the
quintessential moment was donald trump
when finally addressing what happened on
january 6 2021
saying his main complaint is they only
talk about the rioters they don't talk
about how big his crowd was on that day
take a look at this that crowd they talk
about the people that walked down to the
capitol they don't talk about the size
of that crowd i believe it was the
largest crowd i've ever
spoken before
and they were there to protest
the election you were there right am i
right
i think it was the largest crowd i've
ever and the fake news never talks about
it they never talk about it
exactly how many of those it was the
largest crowd
at any insurrection incited by a sitting
president ever and the media won't tell
you that um beyond belief guys i mean
just utterly beyond belief
maybe the most notable moment was when
donald trump made these incredible
claims that he clearly is getting from
right-wing media like tucker carlson and
other right-wing shows donald trump said
white people are being discriminated
against for vaccination and for coveted
treatment if you're white you are put at
a disadvantage on getting treatment and
on getting vaccines that's what trump
said
just denigrating white people to
determine who lives and who dies if
you're white
you don't get the vaccine or if you're
white you don't get therapeutics
it's unbelievable to think this
and nobody wants this
black people don't want it white people
don't want it nobody wants it
it's not even believable you saw this a
week ago where it came out nobody can
even believe it they don't even talk
about it and they don't want to talk
about it because they know
it doesn't work very well for them but
the wall street journal described the
practice
race-based preferential
covert treatments and that's what it is
you get it based on race
in fact in new york state if you're
white
you have to go to the back of the line
to get medical help think of it if
you're white you go right to the back of
the line this race-based medicine is not
so what's the story with this because
people at the rally and on the online
right just accepted it and ran with it
number one this is something that that
tucker carlson's been saying and so of
others now here are the facts on this
because
if people believe this we're really in
in rough shape
white people
i i feel like like an idiot even talking
about this white people are not being
excluded from vaccines
there's a plentiful supply and there is
no evidence white people are being sent
to the back of the line for covert care
as a matter of public health policy what
donald trump and tucker and others are
referring to
is a new york policy
that allows race and ethnicity to be
considered when dispensing oral
antiviral treatments which are of
limited supply
because we know
that race and ethnicity are a risk
factor
for covid okay
the idea of all of this policy is
steer treatment to people with the most
risk of severe disease from covid
and as a result of that we know
that hispanic folks
and black folks as a result of
historical health and social
inequalities
are more at risk of being severely ill
or dying from the virus it's it's just a
risk factor that's all it is
and tucker
i would say trump is doing it trump
doesn't know what he's doing he's just
repeating what he heard people like
tucker and others are are pretending
there's not like a sort of
multi-dimensional
risk factor calculus that's done and
saying white people are being denied
treatment and vaccines which of course
is not true it's dangerous a sort of
fascist authoritarian type pablum
and it's also not true uh trump then
seemingly admits he didn't win the
election this is just kind of another
one of these funny moments take a look
at this we did have tremendous success
you ever hear some of the little
the little uh things where they analyze
elections if you win ohio and florida
you always win we won ohio and florida
but if you win ohio and florida and iowa
and we won big all of them
then a hundred percent if you win a
certain number of states having to do
with legislatures and state we want all
of them every one of them there's like
15 of them different
different little tests and we want them
all the only thing we didn't win was the
election you know
yeah so that that's it
these these little things are just
dropped in where you say oh so so you
are saying you didn't win and i'm sure
if you called him on it he would say
well no i mean that they took it from me
a trump also pushing another tucker
carlson conspiracy which is that the f
it's essentially boiling down to the fbi
did the the riots it wasn't really
trumpists the fbi organized it and did
it all um here is trump talking about
that exactly how many of those present
at the capitol complex on january 6
were fbi confidential informants agents
or otherwise working directly or
indirectly
with an agency of the united states
government people want to hear this
how about the one guy go in go in get in
there everybody yeps get in there go go
go nothing happens to him what happened
with him
nothing happens
did any of these individuals play any
role whatsoever improving or
facilitating the events
at the capitol that's what we want to
know and most importantly why aren't
they investigating
november 3rd a rigged and stolen
election without getting to the bottom
of which we will never have a fair and
free
democracy why aren't they looking at
that
so again trump clearly watching
right-wing media picking up any old
conspiracy that he hears we've already
debunked that one extensively
the other
notable thing about this trump rally is
that donald trump was notably more
transphobic than normal trump
i i don't want to say he didn't do any
transphobia during his presidency he did
but trump really almost relishing the
transphobia here
mentions post-birth abortion as well and
we're done taking lectures on science
from a party that tells us that men are
women
women are men
and the babies
this is a fact the babies can be killed
even after birth right after birth so of
course the post-birth abortion thing has
also been been debunked um at one point
trump
getting that look you know how sometimes
trump looks visibly dazed like that time
when trump said he wanted to
talk about the um oranges of the
remember this take a look at the oranges
of the investigation yeah when trump
said that he had this visibly confused
look on his face he had that same look
when he instead of talking about supply
chain issues he talked about supply
change and looked very confused
we never even heard the term supply
change
yeah i guess it's sort of a mixture of
climate change and supply chain issues
supply chains maybe that's what he meant
okay then trump said america is not
great now this is a notable moment
because
in criticizing democrats and saying how
bad things are under democrats
they're not supposed to straight up say
that that we're not a good country and
trump you always say america is the best
america is the best always but trump
actually now saying america is not great
right now because frankly whether you
like it or not and some people like
america is not great now we're laughing
stock all over the world and you know i
really think the borders are a horror
show but i really think that so that's a
notable change in rhetoric but overall
a really
scary authoritarian fascist delusion of
a rally it's very clear that these are
going to continue there's one scheduled
for two weeks to the day after this one
on january 29th
the lies are going to continue
and one of the things that can't be
ignored is that at this point with trump
as the former guy rather than the
current guy
the people that are going to these
rallies are even more delusional than
what we experienced when trump was
president and i want to talk about that
a little bit next
so in the last segment we looked at the
trump rally itself 2022 has officially
started trump did a rally in florence
arizona it was riddled with lies it was
riddled with sort of uh uh fascist
authoritarian delusions and it was crazy
and trump's doing another rally on
january 29th
the thing i want to get to now is that
people were interviewed at the rally
and these are sick dangerous people but
what's really interesting is that some
of the crazy people at the trump rally
now
are not even pro-trump we've talked
about this split that has happened where
you you've always had the anti-trump and
the pro-trump republicans but now you
also have the pro-trump and the formerly
pro-trump republicans and i'm going to
play a couple of clips for you right
side broadcasting actually doing
something interesting which is as crazy
as they are
they were interviewing people that are
like too crazy even for them where the
the interviewer dude starts to kind of
try to get away let's go to this first
one this is a sort of a former trump
person
um and you've got to really go line by
line to understand the insanity take a
look at this
hey good what's your name where are you
from my name is kyrie billingsley aka
flat earth boxer okay so first of all
this guy's a flat earther his nickname
is based on being a flat earther so
that's number one let's continue
and it's my pr my persuasion that is
clearly the apocalypse and that the
vaccine is made of aborted children now
the vaccine is not made of aborted
children that's a lie and in in keeping
with all of the different um you know
anti-cova disinformation rules on all of
our various platforms i i feel like i i
don't want to treat you in the audience
like morons because i know you know
that's not true but i should i have to
say
the vaccines are not made from aborted
children that's a lie
and a vaccine may reward children being
fast tracked by one man named
donald j trump now that's interesting he
says that the vaccine was fast practiced
by donald trump that's not even true a
lot of these anti-vaxx people
now are mad at trump because trump said
the vaccine works to keep you alive
but they wrongly credit trump with
getting the vaccine done faster that's
something trump wants you to believe
it's not even actually true
who the world's kind of a lot of the
jewish world suspecting might be
a very very good thing for their
interests now there it goes into
anti-semitic conspiracies the idea that
the deadly vaccine made from aborted
children is something the jews want to
use
to
fill in the blanks it doesn't really
matter but anti-semitism is often lying
there
at the surface with a lot of these
people
but this vaccines we have aborted
children and as for a virus that doesn't
exist now covet does exist the the
gentleman says covet doesn't exist covet
does exist we're just remaining in
compliance here they're pretending it
does and the problem with that is that
if everyone's being compelled to edit
their genetics with this vaccine now
remember that the vaccine does not edit
your genetics that's a lie rewarded
children that's a lot like the days of
no one there's been signs that have been
pursuant to all these things the
vaccines came out exactly 1260 days
following the sun i i have to admit i
don't know the meaning of 1 260 days or
the religious part it's less relevant to
me came law in israel so it's literally
the mark of the beast a lot of people
aren't talking about it yeah
it is true that a lot of people aren't
talking about that because it's not
worth talking about but okay so that's
bonkers then they go and they interview
another guy and this guy says that gavin
newsom is dead
apparently gavin newsom the democratic
california governor is a body double of
some kind and again this stuff starts to
get too crazy even for the interviewer
like the interviewer starts backing away
and the interviewer is out of his mind
well
and news is a clone okay they just took
him out yeah so he says this gentleman
says gavin newsom is a clone there's no
evidence that gavin newsom was cloned
he's a puppet
well he's he's well he's a different
level you're right
but uh the real
governor newsom
has had his military tribunal and gitmo
and he's been executed okay there you go
[Laughter]
there you go says the interviewer
um and then lastly and you guys tell me
whether this is child abuse here is an
interview with a 12 year old at the
rally
and uh what's going on at home that has
led to this you're you know 12 what is
it about being a republican that you're
that that made you decide to say i'm a
republican like what is it i'm an a
publican i'm an republican
just my parents really like talked to me
and
and they they didn't really force it on
me i could have picked they wouldn't
care right i somehow think that the mom
wearing the trump full regalia
would care if this kid was a progressive
tell me i you know convince me i'm wrong
i think she would care if who i picked
who i wanted my presence freedom and
liberty and love in the country and the
guns he likes
yes 12 year old likes guns okay so he
likes guns and he's a trumpist what a
beautiful day
your second amendment right
yes that's protected by the constitution
yes that's right you just can't rewrite
it when you want to rewrite it like if
you don't like guns you don't get to say
well i'm just going to erase the gun
part and just write in my own now of
course there have been no modifications
of the second amendment that have been
made you know by democrats or whatever
he's talking about you don't have that
option
you're the best yep in the world and you
live the best country in the world you
got a good mom too good parents i like
that
thank you very much 12 years old well
see in six years i expect you to vote
all right so extremely disturbing stuff
it's
i don't even know that i have more of a
commentary other than to say
we have a really horrifying situation in
this country right now if you've just
been listening today we'll have these
clips in video form on our instagram
which you can find at david pakman show
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpacman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
today i'm going to be speaking with
elizabeth coppack who's an assistant
professor of linguistics at boston
university who specializes in
semantics the study of meaning in human
language it's really great having you on
i appreciate it
thank you so much for inviting me i
think this is a really important topic
and i'm very pleased to be
uh giving my opinions about it yeah so i
mean i guess just to kind of set some
context often times when people have
discussions that are very politically
oriented like uh what does the second
amendment really mean or
what are the
the actual laws around
deportation in terms of what should or
can be decided versus what must be
decided or you know we can think about
all of these different political
implications there's often a split
between
the idea of a textualist interpretation
that is just what's written versus one
that considers
when such a statute or law might have
been written or kind of all these
different factors that lend themselves
more to interpretation
one aspect of this is
are we correctly understanding the
textualist interpret interpretation in
terms of the the way that it is written
and what that even actually means can
you talk a little bit about the basis
for asking that question and maybe some
examples of where the answer may be
we're not understanding the language
correctly necessarily yeah absolutely so
there's yeah plenty of discussion about
whether we should be textualists or
purposivists or any other kind of ist
but there's much less discussion about
whether lawyers and judges are actually
competent to carry out textualism
there's this misconception that just
because
you
subscribe to the word of the day you
speak english and you did well in fifth
grade grammar you're qualified to make
pronouncements about how the english
language works but there's a whole field
of study called linguistics whose
findings are applicable to
these very very consequential
decisions and thousands of innocent
people can be summarily rounded up and
put into federal prison where slavery's
legal by the way uh all because of
linguistic ignorance
so one uh
example of that is in this case called
nielsen v pre-op pre-op uh is for moni
pre-op he was
born in a refugee camp
he is therefore stateless he can't be
deported anywhere but he's not a citizen
of the united states
and he
served a jail sentence for possession of
marijuana
which ended uh seven years before he was
then rounded up by ice and put into
federal prison under this law that says
that the government shall take into
custody
any alien quote-unquote alien that's a
non-citizen
who
a b c or d
where these are things that uh you know
some criminal offense
they might have committed
when the alien is released what is
released mean that means they were
released from the custody that they were
in before
and um
so it says that the government shall
take into custody any alien who a
through d when the alien is released
money pre-op uh was released seven years
before he was later taken into custody
and so
the aclu is defending him and saying
he wasn't taken into custody when he was
released he was taken into custody seven
years later
so he should be released from federal
prison now
and
and so fundamentally this is about the
words shall and when is that really what
this comes down to well there are a
number of linguistic issues that arose
one is what does when mean does it mean
at the same time or does it mean
at the same time or as soon as possible
thereafter and
the the um
the government the trump administration
was arguing for
an interpretation that inserts or as
soon as possible thereafter so it's
putting a little meat on the bones of
the literal meaning it's expanding the
literal meaning a little bit so it's a
little bit less textualist their
interpretation ironically
the government's position was supported
by the supreme court under the guise of
textualism
because
neil gorsuch
tricked the aclu lawyer who was
defending money priyap into saying that
her interpretation
relied on the
idea that this wen clause
which is an adverbial clause modifies
the noun alien
and so he got her to say
yes well sometimes an adverb can modify
a noun which is not true
and
uh as a result
the the supreme court decision was
against money priyap and against the
thousands of immigrants
like him
uh and so they will now have to all be
rounded up because an adverb cannot
modify a noun
there's sometimes the feeling that these
types of
um questions and and we might call them
disagreements or differences of opinion
are basically just used in order to
evade what many would consider as just
or having to answer questions or
whatever you know one recent thing was
when william barr
the former attorney general under trump
was questioned by kamala harris who
asked him whether anyone suggested to
him that he'd carry out a certain
investigation the details don't really
matter and he actually paused and said
what i'm grappling with is the word
suggest and really
huge
political questions about you know
possible impropriety by the justice
department all these different things
come down to
what does he think the word suggests
means versus what did kamala harris mean
the word suggest means at the time etc
these things can these are really not
trivial issues when they're applied to
such important things are they
right yeah and i think
it's there's this misconception that
uh
the textualists are always going to be
the ones who are the more conservative
uh judges or or uh decisions and uh
we're all textualists now as justice
kagan says
and
in this case that i was just discussing
the text was actually on the side
of the people
who
uh on the side of human rights on the
side of people who are getting rounded
up and sent to prison unfairly
and
as liberals we shouldn't be afraid of
being textualists and of uh
showing that the text really is on our
side
yeah that's interesting when it comes to
um when it comes to the second amendment
you know there's been a lot of confusion
about what the phrase
well-regulated militia means there are
some who think about it as meaning
regulation in the sense of government
regulation the way we think of you know
osha and
uh the department of transportation and
and these types of things uh where
whereas others say that that's really
not what it meant at the time and you
have to understand the language of the
time period to really to really get that
can you talk a little bit about the
change in the english language over time
and the role that that plays in us when
we try to figure out what is even the
textualist interpretation because the
language has changed over the last 200
years yeah that's a great question and
uh
i think that gets into
uh matters of
uh legal theory that are a little bit
above my pay grade sure
i
i mean
i'm qualified to talk about
uh the principles of
semantics and pragmatics that are
applicable at any stage of a given
language and
whether or not you decide you want to
take into consideration the context of
the time and and apply that
to the whatever you think the literal
meaning of the words was at that time
that's a matter for you as a legal
theorist to decide uh
well let me phrase it in a different way
if one is making the claim
that we should be going by what was
literally meant by those who wrote
something
we have to take into consideration how
language was used at the time it was
written do we not is that fair i think
that's a decision that has to be made
wow so it may some might say no we're
going to just go by how we what that
would mean today
it is a bit absurd now that you put it
that way right uh so we have to decide
is it the literal meaning of
today or the literal meaning
of then of the time that it was written
and i think reasonable
uh
reasonable arguments could potentially
be made on both sides
but deciding what the literal meaning is
is not a trivial thing it's not
something you can just
say
because you are a native speaker of
english so there's this scalia and
garner tome
on legal interpretation that is this big
white male authoritative
text and they
just
state
that
in sentences of this form
only this type of interpretation
is possible with no foundation and then
they appeal to
you know very serious sounding things
like de morgan's theorem which is
actually a principle of propositional
logic and not a not a principle of
natural language and in propositional
logic
everything is disambiguated because you
have little brackets in english you
don't have that kind of disambiguation
and so some of the ambiguity remains and
so
you have these
these people who are
very importantly placed people
in very big important positions making
pronouncements with no
actual foundation
and
the consequences can be enormous
it was interesting recently watching
this kyle rittenhouse trial in wisconsin
where when it got into the jury
instruction portion where the jury was
not in the room and it was lawyers for
each side kind of talking to the judge
about
what is going to be the text of the
instructions that is given to the jurors
there were lots of interesting moments
where the judge said
my belief about what the
the sort of fundamental nature of this
instruction is
differs from how it's written and so
i've modified it for the instructions i
will be giving the jury based on you
know i'm paraphrasing here what he
believed more accurately represented the
gist of what the jury is to decide it's
interesting that in those situations
it's a couple of lawyers you know
arguing with a judge and it's no one has
ever brought in who specializes in
language to opine as to what what is
really meant by that i mean is that
do do we see that in any different
courts where would they say let's
actually talk to someone whose specialty
is linguistics to figure out what the
intent here is yeah i would love it if
the aclu would hire a a linguist
and i would love it if more
people trained in linguistics went into
law and i would love it if more lawyers
and judges
would talk to linguists about uh the
issues that they're discussing because
they're while they're well
law is a specialty that you can't just
waltz into just because you're a
linguist the same is true on the other
side and i wish there was more
talking between law lawyers and
linguists can you give us one or two
other kind of interesting examples as to
how
uh interpreting text had major
consequences that you've studied and
whether they're well-known cases or not
i mean just anything you think would be
kind of interesting and illustrative for
the for the audience
uh all right
there is uh an example
um
that uh jill anderson has written about
it involves
the american disabilities association
the ada
and
actually maybe i should try i should use
the carico example
um
so
there's a
big a big
uh
drug company
novo nordisk and
a smaller generic drug company carico
and carico wants to make this generic
drug available to a wide variety of
people
and the
big drug company is preventing that and
there's a law that says that the generic
company can make the
uh
the drug available
if
uh the patent
uh does not cover
any of the fda approved uses
uh sorry does not cover
one of the fda approved uses and that is
actually scopely ambiguous so it is not
the case that it covers any of them so
it covers none of them would be one
interpretation or there is an approved
use that it doesn't cover that's another
scope interpretation so not as a
scopely mobile operator one is a scopely
mobile operator and these two scopely
mobile mobile operators interact to
create a scope ambiguity not something
that is taught in fifth grade grammar
right right
um
and there's an absurd interpretation
where it covers none of the approved
uses and there's a reasonable
interpretation
where
um there's one use it doesn't cover
under that
circumstance the generic company should
have the right to make the drug
available for that use right yes
um and
uh
just by fiat
the people interpreting this law said
well whenever you have a negation and
something like one it has to be
interpreted like none that's just what i
decided and therefore we're going with
the absurd interpretation
so the recognition of scope ambiguity
was nowhere in the discussions about
this law
and as a consequence people don't have
access
to affordable drugs right so the the
sort of reasonable interpretation would
have been
this is this is written in a way where
the generic manufacturer really should
be able to manufacture this drug on the
basis of there being
one
use
and the one that was applied ultimately
was this absurd interpretation that led
to the outcome of the generic
manufacturer just can't do it
exactly right wow yeah that uh the
number of instances of things like that
probably would be shocking if we were to
look in detail at uh at court cases um
we've been speaking with elizabeth
coppack who's an assistant professor of
linguistics at boston university who
specializes in semantics i really
appreciate your time today and you
talking to us about these cases
thank you very much for the opportunity
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month check it out at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow alright a couple of
quick stories i didn't want to miss
today uh there are people on the right
going absolutely crazy because directv
the satellite television um provider has
announced that they are going to be
dropping oan one american news from
their channel lineup at a point in the
near future now if you don't remember
oan you've got fox news which is right
wing corporate you've got newsmax which
is slightly less corporate and slightly
crazier and then you've got oan which is
slightly less corporate than newsmax and
even more insane than newsmax it is a
trash uh just pond scum type channel
and um directv has announced that they
are going to be dropping the channel
directv to drop one american news
network as reported by npr
directv will be dropping the channel in
a surprise move sure to deal a massive
blow to the network that rose to
prominence during trump's presidency
bloomberg reported that satellite tv
provider directv
notified the owner of oan herring
networks inc that it would no care no
longer carry the company's two channels
when their contract expires the other
channel a wealth of entertainment dubs
itself a lifestyle channel featuring
luxury goods i didn't even know that
existed uh directv said it made the
decision quote following a routine
internal review a directv spokesperson
told npr the company looks at many
factors in terms of whether to renew and
one question is does the programming
appeal to a broad enough base of
customers
given increased programming costs and
competition for consumers directv says
it's basically a business decision that
was not in the best interests of directv
at t is a majority owner of directv and
you might remember we covered this when
it broke att has been facing calls to
drop oan
over its support of conspiracy theories
um directv spokesman declined to comment
on whether oan's editorial policies were
a factor rand paul the republican
senator
he i guess had directv now oftentimes
people who have directv i i don't want
to say sometimes when people have
directv or dish it's because they live
in a rural area without cable i don't
think that applies to rand paul but rand
paul says he had directv he says he's
cancelling it because they have dropped
they are dropping oan he says why give
money to people who hate us
um so
i guess supporting the exact type of
boycotts that he often
advocates against and then donald trump
during his rally in arizona over the
weekend also alluded to the oan thing
and he says the channel was threatened
by woke executives
at a t and t
and he also says boycott a t take a look
at this but you know what one american
news has done a great job and here's the
story what just happened
the woke executives i don't know what
the hell they're doing they have so much
debt att is a company that is in serious
trouble
and they need a t
and a t saying that they may no longer
agree to carry this network that's doing
very well you know why because people
told them not to do it so maybe what we
should do is not use a t you know if we
did
if we did what they do
to republican companies we would have no
difficulty we just don't do it it seems
like not nice right but they're not nice
yeah
so uh i mean listen this is all again
their backwards version of freedom and
it's going to come up in the next
segment as well we talked about it at
the top of the show
they say let businesses do whatever they
want they say these woke boycotts are a
bad thing they say we shouldn't regulate
businesses unless and then all of a
sudden directv makes a business decision
maybe influenced by a t also wanting it
made as a business decision and now all
of a sudden they go crazy and they say
it's suppression of speech and they say
all these different things no one has a
right to be on directv we're on directv
the david pakman show airs on a channel
called free speech tv
and it's on directv and dish network at
any time free speech tv could tell us
we're not going to carry the show
anymore and directv or dish could tell
free speech tv we're not going to carry
the channel anymore it's not a first
amendment issue
it's completely legal
it's
this backwards version of freedom that
they seem to only
care about
when it's convenient for them and then
if it's no longer convenient it goes out
the window and the next story quite
frankly is another example of that as
well
the troubles continue to mount for my
pillow ceo and founder mike lindell
known to us as mike pillow
his bank is now saying
no more pillow mike lindell says a bank
is closing his accounts over fear of
reputational
damage
money problems continue to plague my
pillow ceo turned election conspiracy
theorist mike lindell wright's salon
with the staunch trump ally revealing
friday on bannon's podcast he has been
asked by his bank heartland financial to
close his accounts over fear of the
institution's reputational damage if
they continue to be associated with
pillow
pillow says they gave him 30 days to
take business elsewhere
the alleged representative said the
institution is afraid his bank records
might be subpoenaed by federal
authorities presenting a risk to the
bank's image but the request apparently
fell on deaf ears pillow told bannon he
refuses to pull his money i said quote i
so quote i said quote i am not being
part of this i'm not leaving so you're
gonna have to throw me out of your bank
and lindell quote and end the quote that
he was quoting
okay um
this is all again it's the same this is
all standard banks do this it's a part
of risk mitigation they do customer due
diligence they look at so-called
politically exposed persons
this all falls under the kind of bank
secrecy act anti-money laundering risks
that banks evaluate
one of the risks that banks face
is reputational risk if a bank feels
that an existing client or a potential
client might be a threat to the bank's
reputation
they can choose to close the accounts
conservative subreddits are losing their
minds they think this should be illegal
they're also against business regulation
but they want to mandate that a bank
give pillow an account i mean that
doesn't make any sense
and uh i thought that businesses were
allowed to choose their customers
when it's a gay wedding cake that a
baker doesn't want to bake
but i guess in this case they don't
don't banks have a right to decide
who they will bank for do these
right-wingers believe that having a bank
account at a specific bank is a right
because it's not you literally have to
apply to open one and you could be
accepted or you could be declined i was
once declined
for a bank account a business bank
account i don't remember why it was
frustrating it was something about the
nature of our business it might be that
just having anything that's on air
has has some risk with it legal risk um
but it's like nobody was taking away
certainly not a speech right
um and the bank was not violating any
law they weren't saying david because
you're jewish we're not opening a bank
they're saying because of the nature of
your business we don't want to bank you
um and it shouldn't really shock us
because some of these people seem to
think having a twitter account is a
right it's not by the way
um and management
uh uh reserves the right to refuse
service to anyone
uh applies in this situation as long as
it's not for your membership in a
protected class they can't say we're
kicking pillow out because he's a
supposed christian or because he's white
or because he was born in the u.s or
because he's a man or because he's
heterosexual that would be against the
law
but um the reality is no legitimate
business
should want anything to do with mike
pillow and he is now going to have to go
find a new bank account
we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to david p
here's a little xenophobia to kick off
the week for us take a listen to this
not sure if you'll put this on the show
but listen
you people who aren't from this country
should shut the [ __ ] up right okay if
you are not from the us you have no
right to speak but it only applies to
first generation because just about
everybody here
was born to someone who was either born
elsewhere or they were born to someone
who was born else you get the point but
i guess you you have to be born here to
have opinions
and the story go back to your own
country and shut your mouth you don't
know what the [ __ ] is going on in
america and you never will understand it
yeah uh by the way that's that's a rhode
island accent that's not a boston accent
just so people know we get a lot of hate
from rhode island there's really quite a
um
xenophobic right-wing enclave in rhode
island it's
probably would be an interesting thing
to study uh but this is a very old idea
you know if you're not uh
there was a point where during the iraq
war they would say
if you haven't served you can't have an
opinion about whether we should be in
iraq really it doesn't make a lot of
sense it's a really weird thing to say
um but uh you know i've been here since
age five
and uh i know far more about what's
going on here than in any other country
we've got a great bonus show for you
today sign up at joinpacman.com
to get instant access to the bonus show
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors magic spoon
tastes exactly like your favorite
childhood breakfast cereals but it has
no sugar lots of protein it's keto and
low carb friendly it's delicious without
the guilt get five dollars off when you
click my link below and use the promo
code pacman